actiware so gut wie absteiger als top
drei mitstreiter rimas klappt es
willkommen bei neuen video und zwar habe
ich heute den special guest dabei ja nix
das ist der rüssel
vielleicht kennt ihr ja der eine oder
andere von euch auf jeden fall wie
kompliziert sich so schnell mal treffen
weil der wohnung köln und ich wohl bald
hier deswegen haben wir gedacht kommt
machen wir es einfach so schickt mit
video und ich mach dann so auf jeden
fall geht es darum er ist russe und er
hat mir fünf wörter geschickt oder vier
dich halt erwarten muss das ist
eigentlich immer ganz lustig ich habe
jetzt hier die videos und mal gucken ob
ich das hinbekommen ich glaube zwar nein
aber man kann ja mal versuchen ach ja
und der kanal karussells und in der
video beschreibung checks dann auf jeden
fall war ab und das nabu da das was der
diemel sergej mir so geschickt hat
andrea nahles erste wahl zum supporter
tun wollte ich finde dann hören sich an
wie zu wort hypo unterstützung werden
vielleicht kommt das ja aus dem
englischen auch wenn ich glaube
supporter potter oder deine tochter
sofort vielleicht ja deine tochter ich
sagt unterstützen oder deine tochter ist
es am samstag so gut sein aber wir
machen weiter mit dem zweiten wortes
zweite lautlos geht könnt ihr das denn
jetzt heißen jetzt müssen wir noch mal
angucken
karlsruhe
ich bin rüssel ski carving ski oder ich
bin brüssel
das zweite ist scheiße ich hätte jetzt
gedacht ich bin russe aber ich bin und
ich spreche russisch ist ja fast das
gleiche
da war ich schon mal ziemlich nah dran
jetzt wir machen weiter mit 321
die bahn ja die war ja der ball ist ja
die bundle blut was heißt es dass rattle
ist ja ich liebe dich so und jetzt hier
warte wir haben wie viele noch nennt das
vorletzte ist mit neujahr vielleicht
neue jahr
neues jahr neues jahr beginnt neujahr
habe keine ahnung wann ich sag neues
jahr weiß ich nicht was das heißt in
fast von anfang november aber was
november ist jetzt ziemlich am ende des
jahres und vielleicht hat das ja auch
zusammenhänge dann weil es so weit ist
und dann fast das neue jahr beginnt neu
jahren wird november neu jahresbeginn
und jetzt kommen wir zum letzten wort
und das letzte aktive gut ist ja da drin
und verso und kaká vor wut weil wir ja
das sage ich das ist meine lanze und wie
heißt du hague die wehr so gut fünf
wörter in deutschland 3 wie heißt du
sowieso macht ihr denn so kompliziert
wie eben schon erwähnt der kanal frustes
unten in der video beschreibung check
das auf jeden fall ab ist ein total
sympathischer und lustiger typ und
abonniert nicht vergessen also den
russen abonnieren auf jeden fall
abonnieren würde mich sehr freuen
ansonsten geht's dir oben rechts weiter
mit meinem letzten mio das war ein
kleiner kurzfilm mal was anderes und
mich könnt ihr natürlich auch abonieren
aber nur wenn ihr wollt
und ja wir sehen uns nächste motor
wieder erinnerte zschau